[Música]
boa noite pessoal que começar com um
vídeo da jade para me ajudar
esse é o mundo que estava na sociedade
os animais gente as flores e quando eu
eu acho que quando os meus pais estavam
me concebendo ele estava assistindo a
algum algum documentário da net dio
porque todas as memórias que eu tenho
passeio por cenas dessas produções
incríveis
desde quando a gente vê um bebê se
desenvolvendo dentro do útero da mãe até
o bater de asas de um beija-flor bem em
câmera lenta eu achava tudo isso é
incrível e eu achava também que a etar
depois de formado e trabalhando por trás
dessas câmeras gravando essas essas
imagens
mas foi na minha graduação em ciências
biológicas que eu percebi que eu queria
trabalhar dentro das escolas para que
mais crianças se apaixonassem pelo pelo
meio natural antes de serem
responsabilizados com peso de salvar o
planeta e isso tem acontecido muito
porque agora que eu já trabalho com isso
há algum tempo já estou na sala de aula
dez anos eu tenho ajudado alguns
professores a a entenderem a educação
ambiental é às vezes eu chego na sala de
aula ea professora preparou um quadro
lindo o professor prepara um quadro
dizendo o futuro está nas suas mãos uma
turma de cinco anos que meu gurizinho
chegou ontem no planeta né e nas na mesa
do professor está lá um copo plástico ou
então a mas vocês precisam salvar as
abelhas porque senão amanhã com a boa
vida na terra
ela não entendeu porque é a bela é
importante para o planeta ainda né as
coisas precisam acontecer de forma
gradual
isso tem muito a ver com o que a gente
sente quando a gente não consegue
acompanhar as notícias ou acompanhar as
redes sociais ou acompanhar séries
acompanhar tudo que tá acontecendo o meu
medo de estar perdendo e esse termo é
medo de estar perdendo foi criado nos
anos 2000 por um pesquisador chamado
também herman e ele disse exatamente
isso que as crianças estão sentindo um
bombardeio negativo de informações todos
os dias
e elas não conseguem entender ainda
porquê disso tudo né eu eu apóio eu me
apoia muito na tecnologia também que às
vezes é vista como uma inimiga da
educação ambiental mas não é
inclusive eu tenho uma colinha que no
relógio para ajudar cnpd e trabalhar na
sala de aula é muito interessante por
causa disso inclusive já me deu um
branco ac
as crianças hoje elas são extremamente
articuladas é incrível os papos que eu
tenho com a jade e com vários outros
alunos que hoje tem mais de 700 alunos
hoje e os papos que eu tenho com eles
são incríveis e se a gente volta um
pouco na linha do tempo e percebe que a
educação ambiental só começou a ser
trabalhada depois da revolução
industrial isso foi ontem voltando um
pouco mais quando a ciência era
conhecida como filosofia natural o
conhecimentos e passado de geração para
geração foi o que possibilitou que os a
humanidade nós conseguimos nos dedicar a
coisas diferentes do que simplesmente
sobreviver e produzir mais humanos
e aí o que a gente vê hoje é a mesma
humanidade se afastando do conhecimento
científico pra tentar justificar seus
atos destrutivos no planeta
e aí eu gostaria de citar greta também
está super em alta agora é uma é uma
adolescente mas começou criança e aos
poucos ela foi entendendo isso e hoje
ela luta para que a gente volte a
acreditar na ciência volte a usar a
ciência como uma forma de de seguir em
frente
de novo desenvolvimento humano não
depende do fracasso do do mundo natural
a gente precisa trabalhar a educação
ambiental como uma forma de de que as
crianças se tornem agentes de mudança e
eu tenho muita sorte de trabalhar numa
bolha que favorece isso mas nem todas as
realidades são assim
é eu já tive o prazer de trabalhar em
vários tipos de escola com várias
crianças diferentes e uma coisa que é
comum a todas elas
é o encantamento quando elas têm a
chance de observar uma serpente ou
imaginar sendo existem tubarões pré
históricos no oceano e isso é uma língua
em comum que elas falam ou como o homem
conseguiu chegar nos nos foguetes o
construir um foguete para outros
planetas
é isso tudo me encanta muito molhada
criança mas a gente vê esse afastamento
todos os dias
o conhecimento então tem que agir como é
uma esperança é a forma de fazer com que
queria com que as crianças cresçam se
entendendo como parte do meio em que
elas vivem e é muito legal imaginar
quantos de nós aqui já não fomos pedidos
para desenhar desenho meio ambiente né
aí vem uma montanha uma cachoeira um
peixinho nuvens e um passa mas o meio
ambiente é tudo nós somos o meio
ambiente só jardim falou muito bem no
início do vídeo é nós somos o meio
ambiente nos enxergamos parte desse meio
ambiente é essencial
alguns autores recentes têm falado que
está no meio natural é tão entre tão
essencial para a vida como comer ou
dormir e eu aumento isso eu acho que é
escritora isabel é bastante recente como
richard long e scott sampson falam que
quando na a criança aprender a se
relacionar com o meio em que ela vive é
tão importante básico e fundamental
quanto aprender a somar ou a ponto a um
texto muito bem e eu encerrei a minha
prática muito muito nisso diariamente
eu não gosto de imaginar a educação
ambiental como o medo do futuro é o
futuro é agora nós já estamos no futuro
não é não é por aí
é às vezes eu eu tenho que falar com uma
turma sobre a extinção dos escolares por
exemplo e eu tenho que me me policiar
muito pra não cair e começa a chorar que
talvez eu não vejo escolar no na
natureza talvez as abelhas realmente
precisam ser substituídas por drones e
talvez perder o fôlego aqui o ar precisa
ser filtrado num no próximo evento desse
mas se eu transmitir isso para as
crianças
é como eu vou esperar que elas entendam
a sua parte nisso
às vezes a gente fala das ilhas de
plástico no oceano mas antes a criança
nem aprendeu o que tinha embaixo você
nunca viu um cardume de sardinhas é
fugindo de uma de uma baleia e isso tudo
tem nessas imagens a tecnologia é uma
aliada muito grande nessa história e
nesse caminho que pode ser maravilhoso
então esse medo do futuro me assusta
muito ea gente precisa se basear no
conhecimento como uma forma de seguir em
frente e não como fugir disso pra pra
ficar assustado é nosso
alguns líderes tem focado a gente não
acreditar na ciência ou não acreditar no
método científico para justificar as
ações destrutivas enquanto e as crianças
recebem isso também todos nós recebemos
isso é eu estou muito acostumado a falar
com crianças é uma plateia cheia de
adultos assim assusta todo mundo muito
quieto ninguém está se batendo tem
cadeira voando
eu não sei muito bem o que fazer então
se puderem ajudar vai ser ótimo
aí eu penso que a gente é a minha fala
pode ter ficado um pouco pode estar
ficando um pouco romântica mas quando eu
falo que as crianças não têm essa
responsabilidade não significa que nós
não precisamos assumir lá porque alguém
precisa começar a fazer alguma coisa e
aí é na prática as nossas crianças vão
aprender por meio de exemplos né eu como
a gente está se portando em relação ao
nosso planeta é um planeta que nos
alimenta que não serve de casa que nos
mantém naquela distância certinha do sol
pra ninguém morreu esturricado ou
congelado então essa beleza é o que a
criança precisa assimilar
enquanto a gente precisa mudar práticas
para que isso seja possível e para que
isso possa ser permanente por mais tempo
é ninguém nasce sabendo ser humanos são
coisas que a gente aprende mas nos
sentir parte do planeta que que está à
nossa volta e nos sentir parte desse
disso tudo é o que vai possibilitar a
continuidade da nossa espécie e de todas
as outras
a gente precisa além de tentar lembrar
como seria o mundo se os nossos humanos
não tivéssemos dominado tudo e chegar
como chegou hoje né e é tudo isso é
possível e aí mais uma vez eu me
preocupo com a bolha para a qual estão
me falando que eu estou conversando é
existem crianças cegas crianças autistas
criança
com bastante acesso ao dinheiro criança
assim contato nenhum com dinheiro
já trabalhei em escolas no deserto
escolas na praia como eu falei e esse
encantamento pela natureza é comum mas
as crianças são diferentes entre si e é
exatamente esse o ponto se alguém quiser
conversar sobre como adaptar essa
conversa ou essas novas práticas às suas
realidades do super disposto e
disponível eu gostaria de dar algumas
dicas por exemplo quando o professor de
matemática falava é quanto as balinhas
joão tem pra dividir com os amigos é
porque não perguntar quanto de material
plástico ele está o joãozinho vai deixar
de acumular ou de gerar se ele comprar
bala e não colocar na sacolinha
a professora de artes mudar o a cintura
sintéticas por coisas naturais corantes
naturais é professora de geografia
trazer noções de suicide soluções
socioambientais para suas práticas para
suas aulas é é tudo é possível e tudo é
lindo quem quiser falar mais sobre isso
é só me procurar em algum lugar que a
gente conversa muito obrigado
[Música]